you
here we go here we go wow this is a
tough first round here we go grab some
tempos against that Queen oh that's a
fork oh you can't do that you pinned all
right hmm
I wanted to push their trade
dark-squared bishop here first with
check oh I get that that's gonna be
painful isn't it
kill that night well he was too fast all
right I don't want to remove that night
so easily I want to keep a knight on d6
and there he is
let's come over here so there's no push
oh oh I think I missed my chance for
that he needs to go and now I'm entering
on this file hmm could have taken there
what am i doing oh I guess I could play
out for why not play here
what's wrong with the seventh rank
somebody tell me I need to know what's
wrong with the seventh rank let me know
right now it's very important is there
gonna be some ain't there should be
there really really should why was I not
moving where is the main that rook is a
monster Queen here next main to man well
I I just want a patrol rock on an open
file and then what just say I'm happy as
far as uh just to that extent you gotta
look to that seventh Frank man I do that
I miss that so much
I really do hey I'm just get 10 yeah me
rock an open file who cares
get I'm doing something more exciting
all right let's take here after that guy
moves secure d5 I could kill that
soon and then when that pond tricky
stuff against the bishop he's
unprotected I'm not even sure what
that's doing all right let's go for this
take care on the Queen and Bishop Queen
here I go here first gain attempt on the
Queen actually if she can't move and
still defend the bishop so now that's
shattered mm-hmm it's a little tricky I
have to watch over that Bishop no fun no
fun whoa
what's he up to yeah okay let's go with
this and gameland
okay flight square first mmm Bishop's
gonna get hit get that night out of
there out on that pond what's he doing
now drop back why did I do that
why did I do that I should still be okay
I'll get behind and he's gonna be picked
up next no less than ten keep my rook
right where he's at
King position they're gonna throw in
checks and stuff pay into thread
when my king is on g4 they resigned back
to tournament thank you to nervous thank
you for signing you see that that's
encouraging isn't it ah maybe if I
resign he'll at least say thank you
let's focus on d6
whoa scrap that rook first quick resign
that's a free rug a freebie let's run
back home just in case there's anything
dangerous game that's gonna happen all
right
I was only afraid of Bishop a6 d5
there's your d6 trades how do they
untangle their pieces very difficult to
do that there uh-oh they're all stucked
rid of the knight the only active piece
not here
I forget if you're not gonna take oh
this is gonna be dangerous discovered
checks hmm
it was like there would be something
better I keep him around
wow that King is wild it's gonna be made
soon well I should have taken some of
this somewhere else that's somewhere
else
somehow else even know what I'm saying
should taken with the Queen that's what
I meant
15 seconds time ticker say what's
happening oh wow they resigned back to
term in 12 12 12 10 is it this the guy
that won first place in that last one
he's ready to win again he's got 11
the Atlantis we've played a ton of times
oh okay
squares weakened I get
I'll trade
I want to remove the night so I have
this kick build my center pawn push I
have the better Bishop Bishop eight
three okay Queen here I guess
alright it's coming over here
get ready this is where the play is
gonna happen
that was maybe too fast
come over here I want to keep some
flexibility with that pond I could have
pushed double rooks first no one trade
not yet soon I will hmm right here and
then plant my rook on this square if
he's ever taken this diagonal is gonna
open up clean here um I need to I need
to sacrifice somewhere oh look here had
my opportunity uh I'm winning material
let's check enter finally the Queen gets
behind behind enemy lines right here
mopping up stuff keep pushing no petrol
can't do anything it's me 4.2
Ekans was not a wad oh sorry about that
okay definitely is not a lot of time but
uh he had two queens had two Queenie's
their bishop check if that guy goes too
far and right ready to just take Oh
can't take with the Queen she's gone or
the knight has to return down a minor
piece not f7 next kick the knight be
happy if he takes that was a strong post
oh that's gone hon takes Queen takes
pawn open up this file I'm on the rook I
want to go for mate though
let's check where's the mate here I
guess here and then made happening soon
right there no right here
the King was going for a walk thirty
twenty nine twenty
twenty-one minutes still the melted QB
okay Sicilian Smith Mora declined secure
my queen
that's why I have this a66 stuff they're
gonna go queenside let's pin that night
you get in d5 then see what they do
all right Knight takes I could take the
queen with a check it's damage the
structure get rid of their dark square
Bishop and castle a better structure and
play against the c3 pawn it's the name
of the game right here play against that
c2 pond on push I should play Queen here
let's just cover h7 tricks get rid of
the Queen I'm on d4 as well take the
Queen away I get that with the check now
what let's just come here to cover every
dark square pawn push next activate my
rooks this is a start on f4 right there
I have a seat to both my rooks are very
active now looking at pinpoint g2 one
more time on the Queen here there's a
queen trade but my rooks are very very
active I could have taken already
I could take here making a few yeah
can't defend that back to turn
41:30 oh I have a feeling this guy is
gonna stick around the rest of the
tournament
we might get paired up in this
tournament it's gonna be a big game
let's try and get a center here with III
d4 d5 now nope now this night is
inconvenienced and inconvenienced again
in our wedding material
yeah i pong got out of control
III D for building the center needed to
play d5 much sooner inside Castle and
this is an open file to be careful about
that f7 is vulnerable and let's
challenge this back rank maybe alright
why was I moving there I have my knight
come over I don't like this pressure on
this square let's try this no this could
be dangerous I should have this now
Queen trade I missed it
Queen's our intention here and back
anything Queen takes f6
and then GC
was a threat back to tournament they
resigned 56 42 42 that was fairly quick
oh okay
48 seconds to a minute ten all right all
right still go forward with this no hang
on hang on okay I could have just taken
that Bishop too could have also done
that kicked my night away gee Foursquare
very tempting take with the pond all
right let's open up the G file how about
that let's make sure d4 doesn't get in
first let's try this I'm definitely
taking the dark square bishop now push
this file is getting ripped right open
my bishop is now going crazy he's on the
loose bishop age three Knight d4 f3
stops fish of h3 this is winning
material rook here I guess Knight into
this square let's go here instead Bishop
takes Bishop with check now but then
there's gonna be some discovering I
should hit the queen that bishops pinned
let me double up my queen was hit why
not take the bishop could still take him
and whoa hang on hang on whenever
there's a knight that's close it's
dangerous when there's a knight that's
close it's definitely dangerous where's
the main discoveries its guard here and
then I could get my queen of g5 okay
they're gone on the defensive which
allows me to get more aggressive Queen
here or just move the bishop and then
queen h5 yeah Queen eh
I've to here next to block with the
night they're down on time back to term
in 72 72 who's this guy it's another guy
that's up there halfway point
juicy ketchup oh man
okay played this guy before okay
Queen c2 Bishop d3 getting essential
expansion this move will help me get in
that central expansion because I want to
play f3 you can't do this move you're
dropping upon so that's why this is a
little bit off I let's keep some pieces
on the board can I do something have
Knight f4 moves with tempo I like that
it's a free pawn let's go here with
check with Knight f4 to follow something
bad is gonna happen here I think let's
remove the darks the LightSquared Bishop
first and let's take I'm dropping this
but they're maybe gonna run into that's
a fork fork and a half right there
that's a very dangerous fork okay let's
actually defend here first I think they
had something with like the Queen no no
there was a better way right here oh my
goodness oh okay I thought the Queen
here and then made on each two would
have been bad oh that might have been a
mouse slip right here no matter what
that's that's tough now down a rook they
resigned back to Turman 90-87 72 72 14
minutes remain
oh man ninety eighty 77272 too close too
close all right all right let's get this
guy out of there I will take him and can
I still go for this let's try it all
night moves my dark squares are very
weakened very very weakened oh boy this
night is gonna land right in here
incoming
clean trade so much for my strike on h2
my queen is officially cut off
I need my knight around to defense stuff
that is very important
all right get my queen doing something
even if it's wrong okay keep pushing my
rook really wants to play let's get a
flight square like this I guess rook
over and then up like this
my Knights a super super defender I
should have played this instead my
Knights gonna be kicked from defense of
this square that could be a pain I
really can okay now I'm there in time to
take this pawn and defend let's get here
seventh ranked stuff knight on this
square with my rook on the seventh very
very good I've got one piece here let's
not pin the night let's go here setting
it up Knight here mate two threat rook
has to give itself up that's the only
move oh no there's a knight move get out
of there
need to get behind that pawn okay okay
what
come back get that pond hmm that's a
fork 10 seconds okay this is simplest
just keep moving fast
nine seconds plenty of time
I'm not there okay I couldn't talk right
there if you didn't know this 1:27 you
see this guy I told you he's simply not
going into the night quietly 11 minutes
remain he's still catchable 127 110 here
we go 11 minutes 11 seconds doesn't that
make you nervous that time is just
staring right at you saying move and
move fast Bishop d3 d5 removed the
defender of the King side setting it up
here we go
tricky stuff happening right now um
what's happening right now yeah that
night Oh forgot about that one I have to
take like this Knight takes pawn oh I
take spawn is a good move
all right let's let's take him out then
and then take here that was nice
that was a very nice counter accurate
play right there and now I'm worse well
I don't I don't know if this is this is
any better
it's the structures ugly you really
don't want to look over here for too
long time queenside castle come inside
castle then there's some discoveries
Bishop takes I would love to see that
okay maybe maybe what you finish your
thought already all right I'm fine with
that
Queen is in a very strong position
my knight can post up on this square I
should be alright my coin is a good
defender
I was ready just moved my knight um why
am I not moving Queen here Queen trade
20 seconds each
it's a skewer at the end if Queen takes
Queen I think just doubling rooks is
good
ah the bishop has
captured which gives me time for b3 and
then I can move my knight if Bishop f6
okay he's he's safe
maybe rook takes Knight B to stuff no
time though less than two anything
anything just want to burn their time
less than a minute they have to check
the server Novak determent 167 187 we
might be paired up it just changed wha
which has happened there was an error
was I just gonna be paired up with that
guy
Oh what just happened there Wow he's
like getting so many points so many okay
I'm not whining and I I wanted to come
off like that yes you are you're wine
and quit it right now okay let's take
this bond he's free isn't he here we go
96 there he goes he's there to stay huh
all right let's get on aged seven
there's no there's no night over here to
defend stuff I like him too much too
much to give him up that easily my
Knights a machine right here on d6 he
really is he really is I could have
taken this Knight how many times stake
here let's kick that Knight first really
oh let's do this first there was gonna
be some Knight takes Knight and I was in
a pin and I will take here that's a
check I'm over here push this pawn yeah
it's getting a little dangerous rook d6
rook d6 swing my queen right over if
that pawn captures where is she going
stop it right now
oh my goodness I don't like how close
Oh where's my time tank oh come on
so dangerous making one threats okay
King h2 Queen here okay here no matter
what five seconds
okay time birders maybe me I could take
the palette mate here anything you can't
catch my pond it's too fast
are we doing how we doing with the time
not a lot not a lot of time I can't
breathe oh no got ponds and stuff
they've got a tiny bag to turn in 207
150
I could never breathe breathe oh man
it's so tough it's tough trying to play
bullet chest when you can't breathe
properly Oh
thirsty McNuggets is in the chat there
he said give a quick shout out during
the during the stream okay gather
yourself man gather yourself
here we go you know I have a
LightSquared bishop I want mine to be a
pest and a half that's the plan if your
opponent gives you their LightSquared
Bishop make sure your LightSquared
bishop is the big bad wolf knight years
nice he's no longer to pin I'm gonna get
forked I should have something now Queen
h4 looks super duper appealing right
with Queen f2 Queen takes rook Queen
takes h2 stuff this is what I was
talking about let's sing Queen here Oh
Queen Esther block and then I get to
take the
on with check and then let's take here
and then undermine the night okay mate
threats like this oh this is gonna be
mate now now a bishop has to block so
that the rook can defend the back rank
but then there's and there's some tricky
discoveries now it's gonna still end up
in May I eventually give a discovery
night D one Bishop here Bishop takes
King each one night F to 91 and then
rook f1 back to term in 205 170 145 less
than five minutes left
will bobsled oh okay
get that night I was like and I was
maybe ready to push him around okay
right here don't give up the dark square
Bishop so easily
c5 was ready to be played what is that
move even doing that's a brilliant move
f3 f3 everybody wants to play off three
yes weaken your light squares you don't
have a light square bishop and now this
night is gonna kill you let's grab some
material that's still it's still super
dangerous at night I just right I just I
just thought I was ready to castle there
no I have to crawl up into a ball never
a good sign let's try this I have to
give up my night I guess can we trade oh
boy my check okay this is gonna be tough
to win not a lot of time take that pawn
would you so I could get at the C pawn I
want my rook active
let's get him active take like this so
he doesn't become past check I guess I
gotta come over here gotta get rid that
C pawn even on time Punk push on d4 I
want to try
upon down bishops there to defend okay
seven finally have good coordination
with the minor pieces this is trouble
there's in that okay can I get that pun
okay I'll take that trade definitely
let's get behind here watch out for the
forks definitely want to watch out for
the forks have taken that okay sell the
past pun 11 seconds out they have very
little time very little time back
determine tadhana time to 25 to 45 we're
gonna be paired up I thought just change
yes we're pairing up I need to win this
game he did knock him down you to win
this one how's this guy beating
everybody here need to take care of this
guy right here that floor might be very
good
okay fine with that
let's reroute my Knight to f5 on push
maybe I need to cover d6 just in time
right here and then night where night
here might be good if the knight moves
especially I'll take the open file
that's for sure I want to get to eight -
it's the main intention with this move
all right all my vertical come back over
I guess we'll go here still watching
over that c4 might be good let's keep
I guess ah they're removing that
defender I takes Knight Bishop takes
pawn bishop here's a pin okay I'm not
sure that's doing let's open stuff up
they don't have very little time why did
I do that
dropping my queen there Wow very little
time my rook is gone any time just run
for the hills she's not gonna be made is
there Wow
they're down a time I was objectively
busted three times over
Wow oh I lost every piece okay so that
guy he dropped back oh but look at the
time it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
Oh can I get a quick kill here meat on
meat on f7 I hope they just throw that's
it that's the tournament ah
second place yeah that guy was just
didn't matter I could have beaten him
two more one more time 243 210 206 he
had 20 games and had 15 hmm 243 210 206
203 200 all these guys could economy
these three man games all the tournament
right
you